[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen
it's halloween that means it's pumpkin
carving time here with some extreme
pumpkin carving tips it's our friend tom
nardone tom good to see you all right
all right having some fun
yeah now uh what do you mean uh extreme
pumpkin carving i don't off the top of
my head know exactly what that means
tell us educators well i use power tools
to make the process fun and easy okay
and this is not something you would
recommend for children is that right no
i don't usually let my kids do that okay
not usually but yeah not usually still a
lot when they're drunk
oh when they're drunk yeah that's a
great dad uh
you're a perfect guy to do this all
right we need the proper safety
equipment first yeah
and i should probably take off this
thing right now
wow
it got a lot hotter down here i just
flexed and my jacket flew off
i didn't use my arms at all all right
i've got these uh gloves here and then
uh let's proceed uh what do we do first
to the man
wow i feel like
it's like o.j
i know
there literally we didn't try these on a
rehearsal these are small i got big
hands
no it really doesn't line up
okay and i got my goggles all right so
uh so i cut the top right i'm ready for
extreme pumpkin carving
so i cut off the top of the pumpkins
with a drywall knife and then i you use
a drywall knife instead of a regular
knife yeah yeah that works really well
cool cool tip extreme yeah and then i
use the pumpkins uh you use an extreme
spoon
this is the part where i'm flying that's
my extreme spoon that's right all right
so you use that yeah that looks pretty
heavy now hand me that tube and turn on
the shotgun
now stream okay all right what is this
right you call this the brain bucket use
it to suck out the goop you suck out the
goop yeah hit the button okay i can do
that
oh look at that
that is fantastic yeah
that makes it so much easier why doesn't
everybody do this i don't know i guess
they don't have a brain bucket at home
[Laughter]
that's enough
[Music]
that was i love that that was so much
better than this because it takes hours
to scoop the worst part all right all
right turn your guy around all right oh
that's scary yeah
and then uh
it's not scary at all that's a
delightful gentleman right there
it's a happy guy that's a guy who loves
life so you want to use some power tools
yes i do all right pick up the drill can
be good for doing the eyeballs
yeah so do the eyeballs with the drill
yeah just tap it in there
oh my god that feels so great to do that
i love that all right
i know to do the other one
you've only done one there remains
another eye
i know what i'm doing here that's okay i
just gave myself some acne but that's
all right
all right and then i claw this out and i
claw that out
sweet yeah and then to speed things up
we have this a cordless jigsaw you use
that jigsaw yeah i got one for you too
look there you go that's cool got it got
the safety right here what do you do dab
it in there pull the trigger and go
i'm doing my hair first
yeah that looks good
you go
i'm not doing this right at all
i'm just making a big wound
[Music]
you want to move on to the next tool no
okay that was pretty cool yeah it came
out all right but i see
i see the overall concept of what i
would do
uh were i uh coordinated and not uh
desperate uh to get this done okay big
chunks came out
that's nice
[Applause]
[Music]
that camera up there all right fantastic
are you ready for a little more power
yes okay let's crank it up man these are
called angle grinders they spin this
thing around and they can be used to
take the skin off the pumpkin
like this
oh wait a minute
what the hell was that
that all went in my face that's why i
have the glasses the glasses are just
here
i got like 40 ounces of pumpkin on my
face all right yeah you try get in there
tight kid is that any of that showing up
on no i'm just that color
[Applause]
that's not anyway
it's not funny
third grade was hell all right what do i
do yeah right there
and what am i i don't even know what i'm
doing just so shave off the skin to give
it some fangs
[Music]
whoa you broke it i broke the blade
awesome
you want to see something else i brought
look at this this one vomits
[Applause]
whoa look at that
that's fantastic
i hope my basement doesn't flood because
that's our sump pump
so that's now where would you even set
something like that up i have no idea
where that would be set up not really
sure maybe the yard how about the yard
so you'd just be shooting green water
out onto the street oh into a bucket the
trash barrel oh okay have you done that
have you done it before i'm sorry it's
ingenious it's ingenious i didn't
realize all right
it's ingenious
arbonne over here okay you're getting
frustrated is this frustrating yeah this
is i'm filled with a lot of anger and
rage because when i find pumpkin carving
frustrated i use this tool what is that
i call it a pumpkin ninja tool you use
it to punch out the face that's the most
dangerous of the ninjas probably the
pumpkin pumpkin ninja yeah
it's not the most precise tool no it's
not you want to try
look at the face you made
that guy's eyes are all over the place
all right this is what you're this is
for the guy who's in way too much of a
rush that's right daddy let's do the
pumpkin all right we'll do it
i'll just do it real fast
oh yeah
okay that didn't work oh wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait look at
that that worked out great look at that
and then right here
okay that one oh yeah it's hard to get
keep going
now you're being patronizing
no
okay this guy's fantastic yeah fantastic
you're a great student it's quick
you want to smash pumpkins do i want to
smash pumpkins there's only one correct
answer to that i think so and it's no
that's all the time we have no i want to
smash pumpkins what do you got here i
got you and andy
you want andy uh there's the conan
pumpkin yeah looking kind of depressed
yeah i thought look at that guys i don't
know if you can see that but he's very
sad looking
there you go and then this is the andy
pumpkin who seems to be just happy with
himself
all right what do you want us to do
we're going to swing these into each
other in a pumpkin duel to the death you
ready okay grab your pumpkin
clearly now this has nothing to do with
halloween no no this is nothing anybody
would do
this is not a martha stewart craft no
this is not like now it's time to smash
them together all right just walk back
as far as oh that let's really get some
energy here i'm gonna really chuck mine
as high as you can go all right
[Applause]
you won andy won
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god what came out of you what is
in this inside the pumpkins oh i put
chili in one and yogurt in the other oh
well sure happy halloween
i didn't know that i was horrified when
they broke open oh sorry i probably
should have told someone i thought that
was their intestines
so chili and one and yogurt in the other
that's a fantastic halloween treat for
everyone who's
watching i think i've ever seen
tom nardone thank you very much we'll be
right back